in Berlin people's thoughts are with
Paris days after the terrorist attacks
their people are still placing flowers
in front of the French Embassy on parisa
platts Frenchman Luke Boccia is
overwhelmed by the outpouring of
sympathy he has lived in the German
capital for 12 years and works for the
cfb the french cultural center of Berlin
he feels comforted by the Solidarity the
Germans have demonstrated de mediate
Amelia to all these thousands of flowers
and candles show me that the Germans to
want to defend values like tolerance and
solidarity I feel a kind of security
among the people here with their
humanity and empathy what's the source
estoy CEO Park EA has seen how the
terrorist attacks have brought Germany
and France closer together the Germans
always reluctant to take military action
are discussing a NATO mission our Venus
to remind there are joint measures
including military actions we can't just
sit on the sidelines yet sneak up
touchdown war against terrorists but not
against Islam Pacquiao has tried for
this in both countries for years he says
France in particular has neglected
intercultural dialogue and tolerance
mariposa see us last week Parisians died
in the barrage of gunfire but I'm also
thinking of the Syrians Lebanese and
Turks who have also been the victims of
this barbarity suffering can't be
divided oh you been a key one sees for
fair park EA admires the Germans for
their efforts on behalf of refugees he
wants to open up Berlin's french
cultural center to them he says the
French should show solidarity with
refugees especially now after all many
of them have fled from the same is
terrorism he proudly shows the center's
storeroom for those needing clothing the
center also has showers and computer
workstations in a few days it will open
the Avenue which is building our
Facebook page is called Bienvenue
refugees Berlin
it's a gathering of French speakers in
Berlin who want to help the refugees the
center also has a stage where Pacquiao
wants to organize more intercultural
encounters now more than ever but it
hasn't grown easier to motivate people
to that end after the attacks in Paris
people feel threatened in Berlin too I
know clonise I just got a message on
facebook bomb found at Alexander Platz
that creates fear of course moon does
not naturally Shang's when Pacquiao
walks home he passes the Turkish and
Arab shops invading district he loves
the city's colorful diversity he will
continue to support it together with
Germans and migrants the emissions was
on we have to stand together yeah this
is that has to be our goal for a better
world invisible vent through Keegan many
French have become interested in how
germany deals with its immigrants mangy
dog does finish dog there are
deficiencies in the integration of
immigrants in germany but here the city
isn't characterized by the formation of
ghettos get to like we have in france
been busy videos in shanghai carbon
hockey a is convinced that ghettos have
led to the radicalization of young
Muslims all day today he's been
promoting dialogue between the cultures
in the evening he sits exhausted in a
French bistro sadness Wells up once
again
the seconds and that's why we're sitting
here drinking red wine it's really hard
to find energy energy status fair to fin
go to a while yeah but I'd like to say
I'm not afraid but I am afraid but at
the moment I mostly feel outraged
outraged at terrorism but Luke [ __ ] an
his friends in Berlin don't want to let
fear paralyze them they will continue to
work for a Europe that is open to the
world